I'm leaving in a few days to meet the
man that I've fallen in love with Lisbon
AKA soldier boy for the first time in
person he is my best friend my confidant
we complete each other he is my baby
loved one do the Oreo cookie okay try it
you might like it
I'm telling you try a Nigerian you might
like him Jim yeah I'm cool my friends
are very skeptical because he is from
Nigeria but I'm very sure because our
love is very real
so you have a day get to leave I'm gonna
be leave in a couple days so what y'all
gonna do over there well we will be
married over there in Nigeria god help
so about nine months into the
relationship Ozma had called me on video
and he said baby love will you marry me
I was like what did you just say he said
will you marry me
I said I'm accepting your proposal under
the stipulation that is temporary
because I wanted to be in person
I know it's crazy to marrying someone
that I have not physically met but I
have never talked like this in my life
[Music]